what is in these pockets look at this  tie what are you wearing do it open it  open it I forgot my candy okay it's  gonna happen so you're not you're not  whatever Eric no thank you thank you  thank you  how are you doing I'm great I'm happy to  be here it's been crazy this past two  weeks so I'm looking alive yeah right  what an emotional roller coaster tell me  about it  are you excited to see it people are  freaking out Taylor Swift is here I mean  so many people uh Selena Gomez very  excited to see Selena he's good yeah  hey blues you love me yes come on it's  my jam you drive in having to cry that's  what I was listening to do in the car  thank you tell me a secret about this  outfit all right I'll tell you a secret  I tried it on at 6:00 in the morning  today let's go this is perfect let's  just go let's go right now ask you the  bomb  [Music]